In the last video we covered quite
a few acronyms describing many of
the different protocols out there for
implementing web APIs.
In this video, let's do some
side-by-side comparisons in order to
determine which technology is best for
what we want to accomplish.
SOAP and
REST have both been proven as two viable
options for implementing a web service.
Soap was originally developed
by Microsoft in 1998.
For SOAP we are obliged to use XML for
our data structures, but
can choose HTTP or another underlying
application-level protocol.
REST was more of a description
than a development project.
The acronym first appeared in
a dissertation by Roy Thomas Fielding in
the year 2000.
REST uses the HTTP verbs in order to
access and manipulate resources, but
can use any type of messaging protocol
to structure the data it sends.
In order for
an application to be truly restful,
it must adhere to a set of constraints
Fielding defined in his dissertation.
So it seems we still have two good
options, but let's take a look at
the popularity of the two
implementation options over the years.
>From this data gathered by
programmableweb, we see that
REST has gained an outstanding
popularity over the past decade.
A major reason for
this is because REST is generally
easier to implement than SOAP.
And for web developers, working with
HTTP is already a familiar practice.
For these reasons, this course will
focus on designing RESTful web APIs.